desde su punto de vista que tan
preocupados deberíamos estar por esta
nueva variante del coronavirus
hola buenos dias andrés gracias por la
invitación
pues que tan preocupados si deberíamos
estar preocupados debemos seguir todas
las indicaciones que nos han sido dadas
hasta ahora por la organización mundial
de la salud las indicaciones que nos ha
dado también la red para la supervisión
genómica de sudáfrica que fueron los
primeros que dieron su rueda de prensa
digamos generaron la alarma inicial es
una variante importante y bueno a seguir
todas las indicaciones que ellos nos den
hasta ahora doctor sabes que usted
también trabaja en angola cómo se está
viviendo esta nueva crisis tanto en el
punto de vista social como sanitario en
el sur de áfrica
cómo se vive en este momento pues se
vive con mucha
mucho negativismo
se siente como una pesadilla como que es
algo que no acaba y como ustedes lo han
visto a través de todos los medios se
siente que sí como si fuera un castigo
para el continente africano
especialmente para los países estamos
acá en el sur del continente
en este momento no hay vuelos ni para
entrar ni para salir del país
esto no solamente afecta a sudáfrica el
reino unido también ya cerró por ejemplo
la entrada a la élite desde angola donde
no se ha detectado ni siquiera la
primera
persona con omicron y 7 otros países
eeuu igualmente entonces ahí hay mucho
recibí mucho pesimismo mucho que
negativismo y se habla casi hasta de que
una especie de aparte de vacunas
actualmente justamente porque tenemos un
porcentaje de población vacuna está por
debajo del 30 por ciento específicamente
en sudáfrica
y eso ha llevado justamente al
desarrollo de variantes como micro a
propósito de las vacunas doctor
sudáfrica ha asegurado sentirse
castigada por estos cierres que han
impuesto a otros países cree que el
mundo ha castigado a áfrica al no
garantizarle un acceso equitativo a las
vacunas qué impacto ha tenido y tendrá
esto
se siente realmente como un castigo
obviamente se entiende desde el punto de
vista de salud pública que se trate de
inmediato a hacer una reacción y les
diría en una reacción
inmediata de tipo
reacción o sea
de inmediato el jueves cuando se hizo la
rueda de prensa por parte de la entidad
de salud sudafricana hablando de una
posible nueva variante de inmediato
empezaron a cerrar fronteras desde desde
europa
entonces si se vive es mucho negativismo
y hablando justamente de vacunas que
llegaron las vacunas y siguen llegando
muy tarde a todo el continente del
áfrica en sudáfrica menos del 30 por
ciento de la población está vacunada y
mucha una buena crear una gran parte de
la población todavía tampoco quiere
vacunarse por mala información
entonces es una situación muy complicada
nuevamente se entiende desde desde el
punto de vista de salud pública que se
quiera cerrar fronteras pensando que eso
va a demorar la aparición en otras
partes pero como ustedes ya lo han visto
ya la variante es de detectó en europa y
nadie les está cerrando las fronteras a
esos países donde se ha detectado sino
que cada vez más otros países africanos
vienen siendo limitados